in the early days people are looking for
the big carrot they want the big Vision
they want the big passion but they don't
have it I'll give you the first rule of
Entrepreneurship that I have learned
which is use what you have and a lot
more people have pain a lot more people
have anger a lot more people have shame
and if you can use that as your gas in
the beginning you'll eventually get to a
point where you can get out of that Loop
and then find something that you are
really passionate about but if you can't
tie your shoes you can't lift the weight
you can't send the DM then you have to
start with whatever you have and so for
me it was hatred of my current exist
since